O On se croirait dans un livre
dede science-fiction, mais on et
bibien à la Chambre des Commune!
HiHier, les députés canadiens
onont approuvé une motion bien
spspéciale : des modifications
seseront apportées au Code
crcriminel pour permettre des
popoursuites pour des crimes
cocommis sur la Lune ou en orbi.
O On en discute Stephen Angers,
avocat criminaliste.
- - Bonjour.
- - Le Code criminel dépasse
mamaintenant l'orbite terrestre.
PoPourquoi il faut prévoir des
nonouvelles dispositions? Un cre
c'c'est un crime peu importe oùl
esest commis.
- - En effet, le Code criminel
dodoit s'adaptait, la société
s's'adapte par des adoptions des
didispositions au fur et à mesue
dedes changements dansns la soc.
IcIci, on voit que puisqu'on est
alallé en orbite et on va sur la
lulune de plus en plus facilemet
jeje présume avec... maintenant,
avavec les Musk de ce monde. On
pepense à un crime qui pourra êe
cocommis dans une station spécie
ouou bien un détournement d'un
vavaisseau spatial. À ce moment,
onon prévoit ces crimes.
- - C'est affolant. Ce ne sont s
dedes nouveaux crimes, ce sont s
vrvraies crèmes qui existent das
lele Code criminel. Vous parlez
mmême de fraude. Il y a eu un
asastronaute qui avait accédé au
cocontre conjoint pendant qu'ele
ététait dans l'espace. Ce n'est
papas des nouveaux crimes, maisl
fafaut les prévoir dans le Code
crcriminel?
- - Ce ne sont pas des nouveaux
crcrimes. Ce qui est nouveau par
cocontre, c'est la territoriali.
QuQui a juridiction lorsqu'il ya
unun crime qui est commis alors
quque nous sommes en orbite? Ce
quque les législateurs ont prév,
c'c'est soit le lieu de résidene
dudu citoyen ou le lieu de
rérésidence de la victime du cre
ouou du pays qui a organisé la
mimission spatiale. Il serait
ininvité à ce moment à déposer s
acaccusations contre les suspec,
l'l'individu qui.
- - L'espace, c'est vaste, la le
c'c'est loin évidemment aux
tétémoins il y en a. C'est un
pepetit peu... pas simple d'enqr
susur un crime éventuel qui sert
cocommis en orbite ou même à
l'l'intérieur de la station
spspatiale. Il me semble que çaa
cocompliquer les affaires. Ce
n'n'est déjà pas simple sur ter.
- - À ce moment, on va prendre..
dadans les stations spatiales, n
vava voir souvent il y a des
cacaméras. Il y a aussi le fait
ququ'il y a souvent plusieurs
asastronomes qui sont à bord dea
mmême station spatiale. À ce
momoment, ils deviennent des
tétémoins directs oculaires. Vos
avavez également toujours la
prpreuve circonstancielle, une
prpreuve d'opportunité par exeme
sisi on va éliminer toutes les
auautres possibilités et conclue
ququ'il y a une seule personne i
pepeut avoir commis un crime. La
prpreuve va être administrée coe
popour n'importe quel autre crie
ququi va être jugé devant une cr
dede la justice criminelle.
SoSouhaitons à tantôt qu'un cri,
unun crime, peu importe où il et
cocommis. On sait que la société
s's'adapte à la nouveauté. Est-e
ququ'il pourrait y avoir des
nonouveaux crimes parce qu'au fl
dedes ans, on n'en avait des
nonouveaux apparaître par exempe
leles cyber harcèlement, cyber
pépédophilie, cyberintimidation.
AlAlors il y a même des crime ac
dedes cryptomonnaie. Est-ce que
vovous imaginez des crimes qui
sosont relatifs à l'espace?
QuQu'est-ce qui pourrait être à
nonouveau comme crime? Je ne vex
papas donner de mauvaises idéesà
pepersonne, mais... souhaite les
nonouveaux crimes dans l'espace,
ilil y en a certainement. Des
fafameux détournements d'appares
dadans l'espace. Ça pourrait ête
unun nouveau crime en soi. Il ya
auaussi l'effet de provoquer
l'l'explosion d'un appareil dans
unune station spatiale ou de
prprovoquer un bris. À ce momen,
vovous pouvez mes que ça existe
dédéjà...
- - des méfaits ou des biens...
- - l'extraterritorialité d'un
crcrime comme celui-là, on le vt
égégalement dans d'autres
sisituations.
- - Justement, je pense que vous
alalliez là où je voulais vous
amamener. Les eaux
ininternationales, les arts, ily
a a des crimes qui se commettent
ququelque part dans les océans,l
dodoit bien y avoir un territoie
ququi est défini?
- - À ce moment-là, il y a les
trtraités des eaux internationas
ququi va s'appliquer dans ces c.
CÇa devient du droit
ininternational public. C'est la
prpremière chose. La deuxième
chchose, vous avez des crimes qi
vovont être commis par des
inindividus, on voit ça au Cana,
c'c'est spécial qu'on puisse
inincriminer, accuser un pédophe
ququi va avoir commis des abus
sesexuels à l'endroit d'enfantsn
AsAsie du Sud-Est, en Thaïlandeu
ViVietnam. On voit qu'au niveaue
lala territorialité, la
jujuridiction, il va y avoir des
vavariations sur ce thème
coconcernant la question de
raraffiner l'administration de a
prpreuve selon les différents
teterritoires en fonction du tye
dede crime.
- Il y aura certainement des
trtraités qui seront signés ente
dedes pays qui visit